okay I sort of committed to not talking
about this too much and just keeping you
posted every few weeks about it but it
is really important for me to keep you
posted about what's going on with the
YouTube ad pocalypse because it's still
really affecting us and at this point
we've settled into really what is a new
normal a new status quo quick backstory
March 31st YouTube because of some
scandalously written corporate media
articles alleging that their ad
algorithm could not properly prevent ads
from showing on racist or hateful
content turned on they flip the switch
on a new ad algorithm and we lost 99% of
our revenue and will actually put our
revenue graph from YouTube up on the
screen for people who are watching
things we're cruising right along we
were having a great first quarter as
indicated by the number 1 on your screen
the YouTube ad boycott hits and we lose
99% of our revenue you'll see at point
two on this graph we are just hovering
above zero okay I'm told by YouTube hey
David don't worry this is going to fix
itself it's going to recover and we did
start to see that recovery around the
number three in our graph and sadly at
the end of June at the beginning of July
at the tail end of this graph revenue
fell off of a cliff and the new normal
there appears to be no indication that
this is going to change period and other
youtubers are experiencing the same
thing I've spoken to them we are now
earning about twelve to fifteen percent
12 to 15 percent of what we once were
this is not a situation that has gone
unnoticed the New York Times in April
wrote a piece about how the YouTube ad
boycott is crushing the David Pakman
show great researched story by Amanda
Hess Wired magazine in May wrote a story
davey alba wrote a good story about how
this is continuing to affect the david
pakman show and this is just the new
normal and this is why we've been
talking about listen we have a lot of
things planned we have major things
planned we've got a 12 to 15 part
mini-series on critical thinking plan
for you we have upcoming long-form deep
dives as we're talking about
into the trend of capital liberalism
into the allegations of so-called
liberal violence debunking the idea that
socialism has never worked a big piece
on voter fraud and voter suppression I
mean we've got so much planned because
there's so much going on but the bottom
line is it becomes a numbers game at
some point and we just have to make up
the lost revenue so first and foremost
thank you to the thousands of people
that have become engaged with the show
financially since March 31st and this
includes both members and patrons I also
want to say that we estimate only about
one percent of our audience is making
any kind of financial contribution to
the show and that's okay Pat I've said
this time and again we do this show
specifically because many people aren't
getting diversity in their media diet
and we want the show to be available for
free to everyone that being said if we
can go from one percent of our audience
supporting us financially to two percent
three percent or on the high end four
percent we completely eliminate the need
for earning a single penny on YouTube
okay so I have some good news along
these lines first of all we can receive
pledges donations of as little as $1 a
month on patreon the addresses
patreon.com slash david pakman show
that's patr yo n.com
slash david pakman show as you see on
the screen as of an hour ago we are just
three patrons short of 1800 okay if we
get three more patrons we will be at
1,800 patrons we want to get up to 2,000
patrons so if you go to
patreon.com/scishow in the upper right
of the screen you'll see that red button
become a patron if you can only do $1 a
month that's more than enough and and
genuinely if everyone in our audience
that could do $1 a month did it the
YouTube ad problem is over okay
we also have membership available to you
if you go to david pakman.com slash
membership you will see that you can
pick monthly or yearly memberships these
can be for as little at $6 a month or
$60 a year but if you want a discount
after you hit the
a sign-up button at david pakman.com
slash membership there's a coupon code
field and you can type in I voted 17
into that coupon code and that will give
you a 40% discount so you know the good
news Pat is we are clawing our way up
when we had sort of what we're calling a
secondary ad boycott that hurt us but
we're again just trying to climb our way
up and we can only say thank you to the
many people that are now involved with
us financially and supporting the show
absolutely when you talk about wanting
to grow audience financial participation
from 1% to 2% of 3% I mean that doesn't
seem like too much overall participation
but that would be doubling or tripling
the amount of money coming in that's
exactly right and that's why when you
hear as someone else will contribute
only about one percent of our audience
contributes and if you can be part of
getting us to two or three percent
you're you're an independent media hero
to put it lightly